bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6000
somme alain dupuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question des lits et c'est une
question qui est excellent parce que le
temps des aînés y at il des résidences
ou des centres de soins où l'on respect
que les valeurs et les cultures des
aînés autochtones
merci lilly pour cette question parce
que c'est une question à la base même de
notre société
la place des aînés souvent j'ai eu des
chocs quand je voyais comment on
traitait les aînés dans la société nord
américaine
que ce soit au québec aux états unis le
fait de mettre des aînés tous ensemble
dans des centres isolé du reste de la
communauté ou même qu'on les ignore qu
on ne visite pas c'est très contraire à
ce que moi j'ai vu un grand de sens où
l'aînée est au centre de la vie
culturelle au centre aussi de la vie
familiale
on va habiter avec notre grand mère ou
avec nos grands pères on va faire en
sorte que les aînés soit transporté d'un
chez eux à l'évènement social qui se
passe dans la communauté
ils vont même avoir priorité pour aller
manger lors de festins lors de mariages
l'aîné est très central mais je
comprends aussi que quand on parle de ch
et celle des on parle de soins de longue
durée on parle de soins spécialisés et
oui dans ce cas aussi il ya des systèmes
sont mis en place selon les communautés
certaines communautés vont bâtir des
maisons pour les aînés au centre de la
communauté pour que les aînés puissent
voir les jeunes et vis passé autour
d'eux des fois malheureusement on a
aussi peu d'accès à des soins de santé
non durée et les aînés doivent être
placés dans des centres plus
traditionnels comme ceux qu'ont au
québec mais la famille s'arrange pour
visiter très souvent les ennemis vont
visiter souvent parce qu'on veut pas que
l'aîné soit isolé soit seul c'est
certain que c'est pas un système idéal
c'est pas un système qui permet de
connecter les nez et la génération
suivante
ce qui fait qu on a souvent au québec je
trouve ça nantes entre les aînés qui
veulent protéger leurs futurs et les
jeunes qui n'y pense pas
à leurs aînés ou passent pas même à
l'idée que eux-mêmes - des années donc
c'est certain que c'est encore très
central pour nous mais c'est des fois
des valeurs qui sont très difficiles à à
garder en vie vu le manque de
financement dans certaines communautés
de pouvoir créer des projets ou des
lieux qui sont vraiment culturellement
sensible donc merci beaucoup du lit
c'est une question qui me tient
énormément à coeur parce que je suis une
année en formation dans quelques avis
avec un manteau donc il faut toujours
avoir nos aînés à coeur et dans notre
pensée quotidiennement soit une très
belle semaine
j'espère que vous allez positive nous
envoyer des questions et à partager
cette vidéo